auchan décathlon renault danone ou
encore leroy merlin ces entreprises
françaises ne veulent toujours pas
quitté la russie en ukraine une enseigne
leroy merlin a justement été touché par
un missile russe qui visait un centre
commercial à kiev au milieu des dégâts
ce député ukrainien interpelle
l'entreprise française
regardez ça je m'adresse à leroy merlin
regardez
regardez ce qu'est le pays avec lequel
vous continuer à travailler et avec les
taxes que vous payez là-bas en russie
ils vont acheter et produire des
missiles qui vont produire des dégâts
commis si
leroy merlin auchan et décathlon font
partie du même groupe mulliez des quatre
on réalise quant à 2% de son chiffre
d'affaires en russie mais l'entreprise
dit surtout penser à ses salariés sur
place on à 2500 employés qui sont là
depuis 2006 il faut se poser la question
de savoir si on lâche ces gens du jour
au lendemain le constructeur automobile
renault est aussi bien implanté en
russie trois usines quarante mille
salariés c'est même son deuxième marché
après la france enfin le pétrolier total
détient des parts de projets
d'exploitation d'hydrocarbures en russie
pour l'instant il a simplement annoncé
l'arrêt de nouveaux investissements dans
le pays